For most applications that
you'll want to create,
you'll want to have some concept of
users to provide security and custom
information based on each individual
person using your application.
So for this exercise,
I will create a new models.py
file with a user class like so.
It is not considered a safe practice to
store actual passwords in your database.
For this reason, I will store
the hash of a user password.
A hash is the result of a mathematical
algorithm that can be used to map
digital data of arbitrary size
to digital data of a fixed size.
If my user database were to be
compromised or opened by an attacker,
it would be extremely hard to decode
the real passwords from the hashes.
Hashing algorithms
are one-way functions,
meaning that they can only be used to
generate a hash from a password, but
they cannot be used in
the reverse direction.
These algorithms are also deterministic.
This means that given the same inputs,
they will always generate
the same output.
In order to create these hashes,
I will use a library called Passlib,
a package dedicated to password hashing.
Passlib provides several hashing
algorithms to choose from.
The custom app context object is an easy
to use option based on the SHA256
hashing algorithm.
To add password hashing and
verification, I'm going to add two
new methods to the user model.
I'll use them later on in my code.
This hash_password method takes in
a plain password as an argument, and
stores a hash of it in the user table.
This method will also be called when a
new user is registering with the server
or if the user changes her password.
This verify_password method takes
a plain password as the argument and
returns true if the password is correct,
or false if it's not.
This method is called whenever the user
provides credentials that they need to
be validated.
All Passlib needs to do
to verify a password
is to hash it with the same function
that was used during registration and
then compare the resulting hash against
the ones stored in the database.
This means that we never have to store
a real password in our database.